there's an eerie sense of calm before
the storm and in ipro people aware of
the horror that could unfold on its
streets and the need to prepare
here at the blood bank the number of
donors has increased fivefold since the
russian assault blood reserves are
crucial in a war
and 19 year old jaeger is donating his
own in support of the ukrainian army
hoping he won't be called to join its
ranks
[Music]
i am afraid but if i get mobilized i
will go
i have to protect the independence of my
country i will do all i can to help even
if i don't have training i wish there
was some military training at school but
there was no preparation
denipro is famous for its space industry
and is at the foot of the city symbol
that the civilian war effort is being
made there's a sense of urgency here
empty bottles polystyrene and rags are
being collected to make molotov
cocktails
they will go to the territorial defense
units in charge of protecting the city
and slowing the russian advance
in another corner of the square sacks of
clothes blankets mats
all this from our heart we want to help
our soldiers for vitaly it's important
to show solidarities with those willing
to put their lives on the line
it's a constant stream of people
donating whatever they can here they
drop water tea
coffee
pickles all sorts of non-perishable
food and this is the corner for medicine
all sorts of medicine including nappies
for babies the city is gearing up
mobilizing and showing support to those
who are going to defend it
the russians could reach the nepa from
the south or the north east
people here are watching bewildered the
streets of kharkiv and kiev turn into
battlefields
we reach 15 year old camilla via skype
her family left her home town of dunias
after the russian-backed separatists
took it over in 2014.
now she's stuck in kharkiv with her
mother the most scary thing that you're
just sleeping and you don't expecting
anything and
like a lot of noise and you understand
that there's a war
and of course you're so scared because
not only our uh
our people like attacking but i you
understand that this is so
uh to be honest i can't explain it like
with words it's just something happening
inside you
it's shakes inside you
um yeah
back in the nipro natalia and her
husband evgani still don't understand
how all this started
of course no so even on wednesday
when we thought about the war so it was
just in discussions but tuesday thursday
morning we were shocked all our families
were shocked
and
they expect that
so this will stop
really soon
shortly after
the first warning that war is getting
closer making these preparations
ever so urgent
al jazeera the nepa